Hello everybody. My name is Alaaniel for Psych2Go
and let's get the obvious out of the way first.
I am acutely aware that I need a haircut.
But we're not talking about my hair in this
video, we're talking about something equally
as cute: Babies. So, Charles Darwin studied
a lot of different things about humans and
just nature in general and one of the most
of the most important things he studied for
this video at least is behavior and today
we're going to talk about behavior to children-babies.
If you have ever seen something in anime or
manga that just made you go 'Oooh, so kawaii'
then it probably has these features as well.
Some of these Kindchenschema features are
big heads, prodominent brain capsules, big
round low setting eyes and big cute cheeks.
So, in 2009, a woman named Melonie L Glocker,
held a research study where she would hook
people up to FMRI machine and she would study
their brains as she showed them pictures of
babies. Now, babies that have more of these
Kindchenschema features would activate more
areas in the Nucleus Accumbens which governs
reward and motivation and the our frontal
cortex which does decision making basically.
The more prominent these features were, the
more activity was found in these areas and
it was a biological and a neutral response
which means that people weren't consciously
making these changes in their brains. It happens
quicker than they had the chance to, it's
just a biological, physiological response
that we have to babies that have these features.
Now, all babies to some extend have these
features but ones that have it more prominent
produced more of this activity in their brains.
Now [Unknown Name] in 2008 had the same idea,
did a similar study and got the same results.
Now, Darwin knew where he was going
with this because species with the same, similar
response to children and babies have a higher
success rate of living beyond childhood. For
example if you think of turtles, they will
lay hundreds and hundreds of eggs and they
don't have this nurturing instinct inside
of them so they just leave and then the babies
hatch and about 1 in 1000 of these baby turtles
live. That means about 999 of them die before
they actually become adults. Now, if you think
of whales on the other hand, they have their
children one at a time and they nurture them
all and their babies have a much higher success
rate of surviving to adulthood. Similarly,
with humans because us humans and whales are
both mammals and we both have this nurturing
instinct to children and we have a much higher
success rate than turtles. Fortunately, but
unfortunately for the turtles. Those are good
things that humans do have this response specifically
because about 13% of women after birth will
suffer from postpartum depression within 6
weeks after giving birth. That being said,
if you feel like you might have postpartum
depression or you're afraid that you might
after giving birth then you should definitely
seek professional help and go see someone
to help get over this for your baby's sake
and for your sake because you're dealing with
two people here. Not to mention the impact
that it has on the rest of your family as
well. Make sure that you subscribe below,
there's a little red button that says subscribe
that you should really hit as well as the
thumbs up button that would definitely help
to show your support to this channel and that
you want to see more videos like this. You
can also follow a site to go to on all of
the social media like Tumblr and Twitter if
you want to keep up with these interesting
facts that they have. So, I hope you enjoyed
this video as much as I enjoyed making it.
This was a lot of fun to record and to read
about. So, if you want to learn more, you
can go to the link below. I will give you
a link to the actual Psych2Go's article where
you can read all about this and more because
they have plenty of subjects for you to read
about. It's an awesome website. Once again
my name's Alaaniel Davis and I hope you have
an awesome week. Bye!